[Music]
Chadd with Alltel Diagnostics with a new
solution that autel has brought to you
for more Diagnostics autel has expanded
your Diagnostics with a new immobilizer
line featuring the IM 508 and the IM 608
the IM 508 features the basic
Diagnostics you would expect from an
auto tell MX 808 plus all your key
programming and immobilizer
functionality this tool is perfect for
your Asian and domestic vehicles and
covers the majority of the vehicles to
program keys for high security and
immobilizer reset the IM 608 as all
those capabilities plus european cars to
do in circuit and out of circuit
programming let's go through the
features of the IM 508 n 608 to show you
how they work the IM 508 has your basic
diagnostic functions being able to read
and clear codes in all modules live data
and graphing it has all the service
functions that autel is known for in the
service to be able to do oil life reset
electronic parking brakes DPF region and
so much more but here's where the magic
happens inside the immobilizer
functionality is where we're able to
program and relearn keys and all keys
lost to your Asian and domestic vehicles
85% of this is done through the obd2
port making it even more simple for you
to use the tool the IM 608 is based on
the MS 908 s chassis giving you the
ability to do all the active tests
special functions coding initialization
and memory relearn's autel is known for
you will notice on the main screen we
have two new icons the immobilizer icon
and the programmer icon when we go into
the immobilizer screen you will notice
all the vehicles that we can do key
learning on when I say key learning that
means adding keys removing keys even
doing all keys lost the programming is
done via the obd2 port
just like on the IM 508 on 85% of
vehicles in North America making the
process even more simple for you to add
keys and remove keys to vehicles Auto
understands that adding keys and taking
keys away may be a daunting task so with
this process we have added all the step
by step features that you need to know
to be able
program keys to your vehicle in this
example we're going to use a Chevy Volt
so if I go into GM I can auto VIN the
car
and automatically pull up the vehicle
information you will notice on these
vehicles were able to pull the pin
directly from the vehicle to be able to
relearn keys and yes that includes
Chrysler pins on this one we're going to
read the immobilizer password and then
we have password reading to go to the
next step
by reading the password the tool will
store that password to be able to
relearn your keys from the diagnostic
tool we'll be able to see number of keys
add smart keys and all keys lost this
gives us the ability that even if you're
missing all keys for your vehicle this
tool will be able to force on the
ignition and relearn new keys to your
car you'll also notice that the tool
provides information on each vehicle
this information includes the key type
how many number of keys the vehicle
currently has and what style of key and
what the key looks like this really
narrows down the process when
programming keys all the relevant
information is going to be based on the
tool simply follow the directions go
step by step and a tool will walk you
through the process the magic of the I M
tools is in the key programmer the IM
508 comes with an 8 p 200 this is where
we place the key to read write and learn
keys to the vehicle on the I M 508 it
comes with an XP 400 this tool allows us
to do infrared keys on Mercedes IC keys
on some of the new Hyundai Kia's and be
able to do a EEPROM functions on
European vehicles the I M 608 also comes
with a J 2534 flash programming device
for more information about the Alltel
line of immobilizer tools visit auto
Telkom
[Music]